what i see here in our theory is
our theory of combination will get us to
ever bigger and bigger infinities but
there's no limit and so i
i can't start with a theory of the one
big consciousness because i can never
get there
what i can do is have a theory of
conscious agents that sort of is forever
approaching
the the highest level but but
at every point my theory will say you're
not there because oh you're now at level
50 of cantor's hierarchy now you're
level 100 but there's an infinite number
of levels so what's interesting about
this scientific theory is that there
will be no room for um
hubris or dogma because the theory
itself will be telling you there's
infinitely more steps to go
and you're only at step one one billion
but there's an infinite number so this
is really
a very very when you do this you get the
fractal notion that you were talking
about but you get the mathematics coming
back and saying exactly how the fractal
works and also telling you um be very
very humble because your mathematical
theory will never get to the
the final description there's no
scientific theory of everything even a
theory of consciousness
yeah and it see that seems to really fit
with the idea that most mystical systems
are apophatic that is if you if you read
many of the the more famous mystics or
if you look at
different non-dual systems they tend to
always have this it's an infinite
regress there is no positive statement
of the infinite it's always a a constant
denial of that which was
or a constant shedding of that which was
below but there is no reaching the point
even saint gregory nisa talks about
let's say the ascent into god as being
infinite that infinite in the sense that
there is no end to it it's not a it's
not a stasis you don't become an angel
sitting on a cloud you know with wings
and a harp there's this kind of infinite
uh
movement up up the hierarchy of beings
um and so it seems to show this this
this this
hierarchy as being as being infinite
similar to what you seem to be described
absolutely and so
once again i think that there's there's
no
contradiction between what i'm saying
and these these other spiritual ideas
the the idea is to simply take them
seriously enough to make them precise
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
hello everyone i am very excited to
present to you my discussion with don
hoffman
don often is a professor he's a
scientist at the university of
california irvine
many of you watching this will already
have seen interviews with him will know
a little bit what his theories are
he is known for his work on cognitive
science the science of perception but he
is also working on a model of reality a
mathematical model which would describe
reality as emanating
mostly from consciousness
and i've listened to many interviews
with him and i've read some of his work
and i'm very fascinated to see where his
ideas connect but also disconnect with
the ideas that i'm presenting to you in
the symbolic world
and i was quite surprised i kind of
pressed him on some of the questions he
answered very graciously and i was very
surprised to see the places where really
our ideas connect and you will notice on
your own the places where they didn't uh
totally connect but i was surprised how
much
uh of his ideas are attuned to what we
talk about at the symbolic world it is
in a way a continuation of my recent
discussion with cognitive scientists
like ian mcgillcrist and also bernado
castro and i think you will enjoy it
tremendously
what i'm hoping to do
is i am not a scientist and so i i'm
more of a religious thinker an artist
and so
many of your your pronouncements and
your formulations and sometimes i would
say
they elucidated me wonder and excitement
and sometimes they lose they bring out
in the confusion and sometimes in
frustration and wonder
so what i'd like to do is to look at the
way you formulate your theory uh
ask you some questions about the way you
formulate the theory and so
not going into the i will trust you for
the mathematics because i'm not a
mathematician and so it's mostly about
trying to understand how how it's
formulated uh and see if we can
understand if you can understand things
and connect them also
to uh to other you know to ancient
religious thought i know you've already
mentioned that that it does in some
places but maybe explore that if that's
okay with you
sounds good sounds like fun
all right
um and so the way that i understand your
your thought there
seems to be two basic uh threads you
could say that is one is to uh
is to argue against the the relationship
between our experience of the world and
something which we could call objective
reality or fundamental reality
that there is a disjoint between the two
that because we've been evolved for
fitness we don't have access to the most
fundamental
um
aspects of the the objective world we
could say so that seems to be one thread
that you follow and then there's another
thread which is to rebuild
a vision of the world which would be
something like conscious realism that is
seeing consciousness is fundamental and
rebuilding uh let's say
mapping back out to the different
sciences and the different ways of
thinking based on that on that uh on
that theory and so the first thing i'd
like to ask you is how do you connect
those two
together it is how do you how do you
connect the one thread which is to
in your latest book the case against
reality especially to
to help people understand that we don't
have a perception of reality and how
does that lead you to this consciousness
theory
great question so so they are two
separate steps and one might by the
first step and not the second or vice
versa so they are in some sense
independent uh
propositions the the first
about evolution and our perceptions
and whether
sensory systems have evolved to
perceive truths about objective reality
whatever that reality might be
that's a technical question right that's
that's really saying we have this theory
of the mathematically precise theory of
evolution of natural selection it's we
have evolutionary game theory so it's
it's really a technical question what is
the probability that any sensory system
has been shaped by natural selection to
to see any aspect of the structure of
objective reality whatever that reality
might be and
to my surprise
there are very deep reasons within that
theory why
sensory systems are not shaped to see
objective reality as it is the structure
of objective reality
i i had some ideas going into it about
why some reasons there
for some reason we might not see reality
as it is but when i my students and my
colleagues started really
doing the math
i realized that the answer goes far
deeper it's really in something as deep
as what's called the the payoff the
fitness payoff functions that guide
evolution they simply don't contain
information about objective reality and
its structure
so so that's that's the real deep reason
why we're not so once you you go there
and you realize okay
what evolution is telling us
is that
sensory systems
have evolved to guide adaptive behavior
period
we thought
most of us thought that to do that they
would of course shape the evolution of
shape or sensory systems to present the
truth because of course you need to see
the truth to be fit and it turns out no
no
it's just
a useful guide the the sensory systems
are a useful guide for adaptive behavior
period and so so then this forces you to
step back and go okay
if they're not showing you a window on
the truth you know how should we think
about our sensory systems
the attitude is that i took as well the
best metaphor that that i have right now
is something like a user interface
or a virtual reality headset those are
two good good useful metaphors but as
soon as you you say that
that we don't see reality as it is and
what we're seeing space and time and
physical objects and shapes and colors
and motions
as soon as you see
that that's not the truth according to
evolution
and by the way i'm not dr near about
evolution i'm not saying that
evolutionary theory is correct
i'm just saying that it's the best
theory we have no competitor right now
there is no theory anywhere near
the sophistication and prowess of
evolution financial selection so there's
just not no other game in town for a
scientist in this role that's why i
studied it i i
thoroughly expect that in 100 years
we'll have a better framework so so i'm
not at all dr near about evolution but
as a scientist it's my duty to take the
best theories we have right now look at
them so then the next step is
if evolutionary theory tells us
that our senses are
just a headset or just an interface
the question is an interface to what
and and it can't tell you that it it's
telling you that you don't see the truth
but it can't tell you what the truth is
so now you have to take
a leap beyond that theory and this is
typical in science you look at your
scientific theories you find their
limits and then you have to take
creative leap where the theories can't
tell you
where to go now what they can tell you
is you you say okay i'm gonna make this
leap and i'm gonna propose this
mathematical theory then you can look at
this projection for example back into
space and time
and then it better look like evolution
by natural selection so so the theory
can tell you if you're wrong about your
your leap right but it can't tell you if
you're right and it can't tell you where
to look for your leap so i i decided um
there's
you could imagine various ways to try to
leave i'm very interested in
consciousness
and
what's called the hard problem of
consciousness how is consciousness
related to
physical systems like our brains or or
possibly artificial intelligences and
and so i decided instead of starting
with physics and trying to boot up
consciousness
since
evolutionary theory tells me that space
time itself is just a
user interface let me start the other
way i'll start with a theory of
consciousness on its own terms so a
mathematical theory of consciousness
consciousness so not
most of my brilliant colleagues and
friends who are working on this
are starting with mathematical models of
what physical systems must be like
to create consciousness or to be
consciousness
and
evolutionary theory makes it clear that
that game is dead
those things aren't even real they don't
even they're just interface symbols so
i'm not going to start with trying to
postulate what does a system in space
and time have to have
so they could create consciousness
i'm not doing that i'm saying let's
start with a theory of consciousness on
its own terms what do i mean by
consciousness what's the minimal
mathematical posit that i could make
to boot up a full-fledged theory of
consciousness and so that's where i and
my colleagues chieftain prakash when you
sing uh robert krantner chris fields and
and others that i work with um
have come up with this idea of conscious
realism and started working on this
mathematical model of consciousness and
ultimately the goal then is to show how
the dynamics of conscious agents
where we're assuming that that's the
fundamental reality for now right by the
way i don't think science could ever
give us a full theory of truth so we so
there's no final theory of everything
from science but we can talk about that
later but but right now this this this
theory would then be
the as far as we've gotten so far and we
would have to then show how space-time
and what we call physical objects arise
as some kind of projection of the
dynamics of conscious agents so we would
have to get back all of quantum field
theory we have to get back evolution by
natural selection or or our theory of
consciousness is wrong so that's sort of
the the two-step picture and it's good
that you start with that because a lot
of people
here's one objection that i've gotten
from a friend of mine and a very very
brilliant philosopher philip goffy he
says look
on the one hand you're saying that
evolution says that we don't see reality
as it is on the other hand you're saying
that when i look at someone's face i can
get genuine insights into their
conscious experiences that seems to be a
self-contradiction
and and you can see now why it's not
evolution tells us we're not seeing
reality as it is
then i say okay next step okay what is
reality well if it's consciousness then
the interface would be an interface to
consciousness so it wouldn't be a
surprise that we would have some true
insights into consciousness if that's
what the interfaces do so that's that's
that's why it doesn't self-contradict
the first is a theory about theorem from
evolution the next is a leap beyond
evolution
but but the
constraint is this leap better project
back down to space time and give me
evolutionary theory as a special case
that resolves that kind of apparent
contradiction
okay so i think that i think that my my
biggest question then
comes in relation to what you you've
just explained that is
if if
um our perceptions if our capacity to
proceed doesn't give us access to
reality per se or objective reality
fundamental reality per se
and that
in order to
fix that or in order to find a solution
to that problem you're looking at
consciousness as the originator
of phenomena as the the basis of a
phenomena
why do you continue to to posit this
reality why do you continue to say it
doesn't give us
access to reality
i don't know if you understand it
i find that that it creates in me at
least a lot of confusion which is that
other people that i that i'm interested
in very much who seem to see the
fundamental consciousness of the
fundamental let's say axiom will take on
something like
a modified phenomenological approach
which is that they will take
phenomenology as a basic framework which
is that being presents itself to me
being presents itself to me to my
consciousness and i engage with it with
something we could call
uh
conscious agency that is care you know
the thing about heidegger in particular
like something like care something like
desire something like purpose all of
these these uh categories will then
generate the world and so you know the
idea for example that objects don't have
identities apart from the their purposes
in consciousness something like that um
and so what i find difficult is that
when you when you continue to say
that
a consciousness doesn't give us and you
could say something what i hear from you
often is that consciousness doesn't give
us access to
reality
and then you you turn around through our
perceptions and then you turn around and
you say consciousness might be the
fundamental
axiom of of
of phenomena i don't know if you
understand the the quandary that i have
in the formulation
i think so it gets back to the first
thing that we were discussing and and
that is
um
i should say right up front i don't know
whether our senses show us reality or
not i don't know
all i know is that evolutionary theory
tells me that they don't
right and also physics tells us that
space time isn't fundamental which is
the sort of the foundation of our
current perceptions so all so those
theories may be false but they're the
best that we have so far so as a result
of those theories i'm saying that those
theories tell us we don't see reality as
it is
now i take another step when i say okay
um well i'm not going to say that there
is no such thing as
reality and i like the kind of thing
that you're talking about the
phenomenologists and heidegger and so
forth that's perfectly fine with me
and there's nothing in what i'm saying
about consciousness that would
contradict them what what i'm doing
that's different from the
phenomenologists and heidegger and so
forth is i'm saying if if we want to say
that consciousness
and and and
psychological and in in conscious
experiences and so forth are fundamental
as a scientist
i know that
that has been said for thousands of
years by various religious and spiritual
traditions
so in some sense there's nothing new
what's new from the science point of
view is we're going to take that
mathematically seriously we're saying
that consciousness is fundamental
if that's the case then we owe a precise
mathematical theory of what we mean by
that
uh because in some sense we would like
to have a falsifiable and testable
theory and we'd also like to avoid
dogmatism we would like to just not spin
our wheels in the same circles for
thousands of years we would like to
actually find out where we're wrong as
quickly as possible so that's why i go
for this mathematical model of
consciousness so i don't think that it's
at all contradictory to phenomenology or
or many philosophical points of view in
some sense it's saying let's take those
points of view seriously enough
that we're going to actually turn them
into mathematical precise theories that
we can test and find out their strengths
and their failures so i just say that so
far it sounds like we're on the same
page
all right and so i think that that that
was
in a way that was my my biggest question
because
so i've heard you formulate things for
example so i this is these are the types
of questions that i that come up when i
listen to you and so sorry i'm not
focusing on the more exciting parts of
what of what you're saying because those
i get and i'm excited about and it's
more the questions that i have and so
the um
so i've heard you say something like you
know when you look at you like you say
you look at a car and then the car
exists and when you turn around the car
ceases to exist
and so this these types of these types
of of let's say
formulations really boggle my mind that
is because one aspect let's say one
projection of consciousness is something
like memory and and when i
when i say memory i mean it also almost
in the platonic sense that is i don't
want to argue let's say for the
for the theory of the form but there's a
manner in which
we we commonly remember identities and
we we all we
in consciousness that they across each
other we participate in identities so
for example the identity of a car
is
exists across my consciousness and my
relationship to other consciousnesses
because i have
right i i learned what a car is from my
parents i learned from a car is from and
so
the idea that the car ceases to exist
when i don't look at it to me is
is a very it seems like a very very bold
statement um and so maybe you can you
can expand a little bit on
on that and and and or let's say in what
matter does the car continue to exist
when i don't look at it because at least
it exists in my memory you know at least
it exists
in
let's say my my my knowledge that other
people also know that the car continues
to exist
right so so i'm not denying that there's
some aspect of reality that continues to
exist whether or not i perceive it there
is some reality it's just that um what i
perceive in my senses is not that it's
just a it's just an interface to that
reality and what my interface is doing
is very much like if you're if you have
a virtual reality headset on
and you're playing a game like grand
theft auto and virtual reality mode and
you you
i turn my headset to the right and i see
a red camaro
well in that
context in that metaphor that i'm using
the reality i'm interacting with is a
supercomputer with lots of voltages and
magnetic fields in it and so forth and
when i'm actually
turning my steering wheel and turning my
head and looking around i'm really
toggling tons of millions of voltages
rapidly in some supercomputer but what i
see
is a red camaro now there is no red
camaro in that supercomputer so that red
camaro only exists when i turn my
headset and create it and then when i
turn my headset that way that that red
camaro existed nowhere else except in my
perceptions so it and since it's no
longer my perceptions it doesn't exist
it might exist of course in my memory as
you point out but as a as a current
sensory experience it will no longer
exists and i'm saying that that's just
what what's obviously true in virtual
reality is in fact what's also true in
everyday life we're wearing a headset
from an evolutionary point of view our
senses evolved to be a headset not a
window on the truth and just like any
headset you render what you're looking
at
as you need it and then you garbage
collect it when you don't need it
anymore and you get rid of it and and
that way you don't keep all this
structure around the fact that we tend
to agree like suppose i play a game of
virtual reality tennis with you
and i hold up a tennis ball and you say
yeah i'm ready and i hit the tennis ball
and you hit the tennis ball back it's it
sounds as though there's a single
existing tennis ball
one in the same tennis ball that you
perceive and i perceive but in fact
there's not i in my headset i'm i'm
looking and creating the tennis ball as
i need to you're creating your tennis
ball when you need to there's no green
tennis ball inside the computer the
supercomputer that's running this whole
thing but it coordinates our perception
such that we have the useful illusion of
a single tennis ball
so so that's sort of that that i hope
that that helps
to demystify the kinds of things i'm
saying would be almost in inconceivable
except that we have these wonderful new
metaphors of virtual reality and user
interfaces that we didn't have you know
a few decades ago that sort of helped
make it
easier in fact my take is that that my
generation has a hard time but the next
generation that's raised on the
metaverse will just sort of yawn and say
so what of course
so i think so i think this is again so
let me bring up another
let's say bring up another metaphor
to try to to
to crack this for myself um
um and so
so i think to me the idea
maybe it's the idea of existence that is
uh that is that that we're that i'm
struggling with that is and so
there is you could say something like
i i tend to have i could i'm fine with
the aristotelian
notion of potential i think there's
potential out there there's something
like potential for existence and then it
it encounters consciousness or
encounters mind and in that encounter
there is a adjoining of heaven and earth
we could say you know to use religious
terms and then there is phenomena
appears as that
but there's also
a sense in which
that is not idiosyncratic and i think
you're not saying that it's
idiosyncratic that it's somehow you know
just me or just my my but that there is
so so most religious
theories will posit higher beings like
they'll posit transpersonal
consciousnesses and the patterns that we
share in common will be held by these
trans-personal
consciousnesses and that is what that is
what let's say affords their possibility
across each other right so you can
imagine things like angels or
bodhisattvas or different
versions of these where
there is a way in which so when you say
for example that the car ceases to exist
when i turn around that is intuitively
to me that it's something it's something
like unacceptable or that or that the
tennis ball
that i am hitting and the tennis ball
that you're hitting is not the same
tennis ball
there's a manner in which
it becomes the same tennis ball
in communion with you
as i am in communion with you that's
when it becomes the same tennis ball
i don't know if that makes sense because
i'm i'm trying to
yeah sorry
yeah very very
very good point so so first i would
agree that
that i don't believe in solipsism so i
don't think that i my perceptions are
the only thing that exists and i i don't
rule out many many other forms of
consciousness in fact countless other
forms of consciousness that are beyond
my imagination and and to say that
they're perfectly real
and also that uh consciousnesses can
interact and that i could be very much
right now unaware of all the kinds of
interactions that are that are going on
there and in fact all of these things
are actually forced on me by the
mathematical model that i'm working on
right now it it actually forces me to
posit um a whole hierarchy of of
interacting conscious agents or
heterarchy might be a better word and
you know what is the difference between
because that because this is really
interesting so what is the difference
for you between the hierarchy and the
hierarchy
well so in a hierarchy there's a strict
upper and lower right so this is above
that this is above that in a heteroarchy
there could be some hierarchy but there
could also be things that are just sort
of sideways from each other and and not
above or below that
[Music]
so that so a heteroarch is i would say
just a little bit more general than than
restrict hierarchy in the way that i was
i was using it but the i i so far again
i i think we're on the same page i'm
simply trying to take these ideas and
make them precise right i want to
actually show precisely how conscious
what what my technical term is called a
conscious agent that's the mathematics
of conscious agents so for me conscious
agent is not an informal term it's a
mathematically precise thing in terms of
measurable spaces and markovian kernels
and so forth
and it when i look at the mathematics it
it suggests an interpretation along the
lines that you were talking about like
potential
a potential like aristotelian potential
um and somehow that potential becomes
actual in an actual experience that one
has
and then one can have a mathematical
theory about okay how
do conscious agents communicate and
share
uh experiences can can conscious agents
actually combine
into new unified consciousnesses and the
answer is yes and the mathematics shows
how to do it i just presented a talk a
couple weeks ago to
um a workshop on mind and agency with a
lot of quantum theorists and and
philosophers and so forth where the
mathematics
provides a brand new and uh compelling
approach toward
actually
taking separate consciousnesses
conscious agents and showing how they
literally fuse the mathematics for
forces you to conclude that in this case
the two consciousnesses literally fuse
and experiences fuse to create new
brand new novel experiences from the
interactions so so
right now i'm on the same page with you
my only thing is let's make this precise
all right and so
this is something that really interests
me as well is that you seem to be
one of the the
the model that i'm experiencing with
is the notion of fractal consciousness
or fractal agency that is the the idea
that even me like let's say as a person
i am i'm made up of a
of a series of capacities for attention
or a series of of conscious agents that
join together into
what i call jonathan but that i that
this could
scale up where i participate in a family
i participate in a city i participate in
other things that aren't so let's say
it's easy to say family and city because
they're bound in space but there are
other types of agencies that i could
participate in which would be
transpersonal but that this also scales
down within the person but it doesn't
imply
a kind of pan psychist idea either like
it doesn't it's not the idea of that
that let's say
consciousness is just a you know a
quality of of matter and that they join
together but there really is a
also a
bottom-up and top-down re relationship
between these fractal agencies so i
don't know if your model has has thought
about those types of things oh it's it's
baked into the model
so so fractals are are self-similar
structures
they they
as you look at different scales you see
the same structure repeated and nested
and
the the mathematical framework that i'm
using of conscious agents is is
precisely self-similar at all scales
it's this is the same structure when
agents combine they form new agents at a
higher quote-unquote scale but it's the
same structure so you have the
self-similarity going up all the way and
you know one interesting technical
uh question that i'm
working with my my colleagues right now
is that as we take a you know suppose i
have what's called a countable set of
of these conscious agents
so you can pair them with the integers
so there's an infinite number of them
and each has its own say
conscious experiences well it's a
theorem of of our theory that when it
when any number of them any subset of
them interact they form a new agent
so that means that
you have
what's called the power set
which is the set of all subsets of these
conscious agents you have a new
collection of conscious agents which is
has the dimension or the the the
actually the cardinality is the
technical term the number of them is the
power set of the the first it's a bigger
infinity and once you then you then
if you take the power set of them you
get a new set of combined agents so this
is your fractal idea with mathematical
precision now what we're doing is
climbing up what's called cantor's
hierarchy of infinities there's not one
infinity there's an infinite number of
infinities and each infinity that's up
higher is infinitely bigger than the one
below it
and so what i see here in our theory is
our theory of combination will get us to
ever bigger and bigger infinities but
there's no limit and so i
i can't start with a theory of the one
big consciousness because i can never
get there
what i can do is have a theory of
conscious agents that sort of is forever
approaching
the the highest level but but
at every point my theory will say you're
not there because oh you're now at level
50 of cantor's hierarchy now you're
level 100 but there's an infinite number
of levels so what's interesting about
this scientific theory is that there
will be no room for um
hubris or dogma because the theory
itself will be telling you there's
infinitely more steps to go
and you're only at step one one billion
but there's an infinite number so this
is really
a very very when you do this you get the
fractal notion that you were talking
about but you get the mathematics coming
back and saying exactly how the fractal
works and also telling you um be very
very humble because your mathematical
theory will never get to the
the final description there's no
scientific theory of everything even a
theory of consciousness
yeah and it see that seems to really fit
with the idea that most mystical systems
are apophatic that is if you if you read
many of the the more famous mystics or
if you look at
different non-dual systems they tend to
always have this that's an infinite
regress there is no positive statement
of the infinite it's always a a constant
denial of that which was
or a constant shedding of that which was
below but there is no reaching the point
even saint gregory vanessa talks about
let's say the ascent into god as being
infinite that infinite in the sense that
there is no end to it it's not a it's
not a stasis you don't become an angel
sitting on a cloud you know with wings
and a harp there's this kind of infinite
uh
movement up up the hierarchy of beings
um and so it seems to
show this this this this
hierarchy as being as being infinite
similar to what you seem to be described
absolutely and so
once again i think that there's there's
no
contradiction between what i'm saying in
these these
other spiritual ideas the the idea is to
simply take them seriously enough to
make them precise and and
you know it's an open question whether
the mathematics that we've got right now
will even allow us to posit that there
is a final unity i i i i doubt it myself
i think that the description you gave
that is the so open-ended and and you
can
never get to the top
is is probably right but but
for me i actually put this out to my
colleagues and my mathematical
colleagues that we want i want us to
look at this mathematically and see what
kind of progress we can make on on
asking is there one
any way to think about a final unity of
all these conscious agents into one big
conscious agents in the limit as we go
to the top of the cantor hierarchy and
right now i don't see it but that that's
um that means nothing i'm not a
mathematician so we'll
we'll see um but but we do have big
hints um like from girdles in
completeness theorem
that that no scientific no finite
accidentization of mathematics
that's uh rich enough to do arithmetic
can ever have all truths
girdle says give me a rich enough system
of axioms i'll show you a statement
that's true but can't be proven it's
true um
given your system but it's not provable
from your actions your theory cannot get
it and if you add my new true statement
to your axioms i'll show you another
statement that's true but you can't
derive it and so what's telling me is
that scientific theories in principle
will only scratch the surface of the
truth yeah
and you might ask well
why are you doing it then and and
part answer is um
i don't know
but the other part of the answer is it
seems like consciousness
needs to spend time in various specific
form domains like space and time right
now and here here we are in this virtual
reality with this you know 93 billion
light years across and trillions of
stars and galaxies and so forth and and
we get lost in it consciousness gets
lost in it
and then wakes up and finds out no no
i'm not a little
you know 160 pound
entity in this vast universe
this universe is nothing but a headset
that i'm wearing and i can take it off
so so somehow consciousness
seems to to need to project itself into
various
forms various formal systems if you will
and explore them get lost in them as a
way of knowing itself you know if
consciousness is really about knowing
itself it does it by
losing itself in a particular like
space-time system that we're in
and then waking up and saying is as
beautiful and rich as that is i'm not
that i'm beyond that and that's how it
comes to know itself by knowing what
it's not
so that that's one reason perhaps why
um
these kind of scientific theories are
important that's sort of part of the
whole process of consciousness waking up
to itself by knowing precisely what it's
not i'm not just that i'm more than that
but you can't know that you're not just
that until you can stay precisely what
it is that you're not just and then you
can transcend it
and so one of the one of them let's say
in many spiritual practices not all not
all the spiritual traditions but in many
spiritual traditions there is a sense in
which there's a double movement you
could say so there's a movement an
apophatic movement which is
similar to what you're saying which is
that these perceptions that i have they
are not ultimate reality they are they
are somewhat if compared to ultimate
reality they are something like an
illusion there's something like uh
like a dashboard the way that you talk
about um but then that even that
illusion let's say
has to originate from something it it it
nonetheless is a projection of
consciousness and therefore it also does
offer us reality at the level at which
we are that is it offers truth to the
level in which we are perceiving but it
also at the same time hides truth
because i think when i listen to the way
you present your system
and when you talk about the headset and
how it doesn't show reality i struggle
because it it it feels like this there's
an arbitrary layer and where does that
arbitrary layer come from if everything
is a projection of consciousness i know
if you understand my question
well that that's a great um
a great point and again i i agree
the headset is just a metaphor that i've
helped people to wrap their heads around
the idea that you might not see the
truth and that might not be bad
but but the notion of projection is the
one that i'm really working with so i
have a mathematical model of
consciousness
and for example that model may not
be have any notion of time in it in the
notion of increasing entropy so we in
our mathematical model of consciousness
it it can be a timeless dynamics of
consciousness in the sense of there's no
increasing entropy but you can prove
it's trivial to prove it's a three-line
proof that any projection of that
timeless dynamics will
by
the act of projection
lead to the appearance of an evolution
in time
so you get time evolution as an artifact
as as something that's in introduced
it's not real about
consciousness itself it's only an
artifact of looking at consciousness
through a particular viewpoint then you
get the notion of
entropic time and and therefore probably
more general limits as well i mean the
consciousness itself may have
might be cooperative no limited
resources no competition but when you
take a projection of it now it looks
like limited resources competition and
uh you know
competition in time
so so
so in that sense
it's it's it's you could say that this
is all the truth but it's truth of a
projection and it's not it's not a deep
truth of the thing that's being
projected
from right and and in fact there are
artifacts of the projection that aren't
deeply true about the thing that you are
looking at so it may be that there is no
entropic time and consciousness
you know
viewed broadly but from any perspective
of consciousness you get the notion of
anatomic time so that's so you can see
how
i hope what you see
from from this is that
i don't think that
i'm contradicting the basic ideas of
these
spiritual traditions
i'm trying to take them very very
seriously and make them completely
rigorous i'm hoping eventually
to have
a synergy between science and
spirituality where both sides are going
to be shocked there are sides things
that both are going to
thought think that they knew were true
and we'll find out as we go along that
well those were best poor approximations
to some better
uh understanding
but i think the two will be a synergy
that
you know with the proper humility and
the proper openness to you know
proceeding wherever the
our theories our precise theories may
lead us and of course not taking our
theories as
the final word but but as the best we
have so far
we will be led to deeper and deeper
understandings of the spiritual realm
that um
maybe many of the spiritual teachers in
the past knew sort of by intuition but
most of us aren't theirs but with the
tools of science many more of us can
begin to start to grasp
these ideas and get help with them
so i think that again
maybe i'm i'm i hope i'm not pressing
the point too much but if let's say uh
if time and space or a projection of
consciousness you know then
how can i say this would they not
necessarily be
a true aspect of consciousness
in in projection that is
true
that they are that they are true
manifestations of consciousness within
the frame that that we are perceiving
the frame that we are existing and i say
that it's in for me
it's impo there's um
you could say there are two big
spiritual traditions in regard to this
right there is a kind of idea of maya
excessive idea of maya where everything
is illusion nothing this is real you
know and then there's something which
would be more like an incarnational
vision which we definitely find more in
christianity which is that
not all this is unreal in comparison to
god but to the extent that it is real
then it is real it can be
something like transfigure that it can
put that it can
that it can lead us towards mysteries
let's say if we if we engage with what
we
what we see properly um but the so what
i with the the let's say the headset
thing and the way that especially when
you use the image of
from the headset to the ones and zeros
in the computer it's a it really is pure
disjunction between
let's say the fundamental
uh the more fundamental aspect and then
the the projection of that in in our
perception
right so
i agree that
is fair enough to say that that
the projection has a reality of its own
and
so for example we talk about sunrise and
sunset and it's perfectly fine and it's
true you know that the sunrise was at
such and such you know 5 55 a.m this
morning or something like that
but from a higher perspective you know
if you take a rock and get off planet
earth then the very notion of sunrise
and sunset is is sort of irrelevant the
sun the sun just shines
so so it's you know it's true of a
particular
perspective that the sun rises at 5 55
a.m in irvine california and of course
that wouldn't be true even in seattle
it's a different time in seattle and so
forth so so yeah you can talk about
truths of perspective um
the
and i i think that there's not
in the way that i'm thinking about our
perceptions in reality as you can see
when i say that consciousness is
fundamental and and that conscious
experiences are our fundamental part of
that that our conscious experiences of
space and time and so forth are
experiences so they are part of this
deeper reality of of consciousness
so so when i'm talking about the headset
i'm really trying to bring home what
evolutionary theory is telling us
evolutionary theory is telling us
that our perceptions
are are not
isomorphic or homomorphic to reality so
with one exception something called
measurable structures but other than
that uh
there's no homomorphism from from the
point of view of evolutionary game
theory so so to bring home the
the meaning of that theorem from that
scientific theory i use the headset and
try to make the point that is utterly
alien but then when i go to this deeper
level of consciousness there is a
rapprochement now i say okay i mean i
now want to transcend evolutionary
theory
the reason i take the headset seriously
is that's our best scientific theory in
this realm so let's understand what it
says it says that this is just a user
interface
and you got to live with that now with
this deeper theory
there is something of rapprochement
because i'm saying there is conscious
agents with their experiences that's
part of the objective
reality now
even there you might say that
what's really
interesting is the potential for
conscious experiences not the particular
conscious experiences that you have and
one could could debate that i mean but
but the way i view it right now is
the the mathematics
lays out there there is this potential
and then when we actually run the
mathematics we see the actual you know
play of conscious experiences that that
potential gives rise to so i don't see
the two as terribly divorced but the one
the potential is is
stunning i mean that that
and and there i should say this as as
much as i'm
you know praising science i want to make
very very clear that i think that there
will always be a fundamental mystery
forever
that our science there is no scientific
theory of everything and
for what it's worth my own take is that
we can't ultimately know
the truth through scientific theory
we can get rid of our misunderstandings
of the truth through scientific theory
that is really really helpful but in
some sense we can only know the truth by
being it we can know it if we're not
divorced from consciousness and
consciousness is fundamental then we can
know it in silence with when we let go
of concepts but we can also know
something about it from our conceptual
analysis
we can know that the consciousness is no
less rich than the concepts that we've
had so far
and we can know that certain of our
concepts are just flat out wrong
um or they're not rich enough so they're
helpful in that way so so
no this is really helpful for me because
it's really helping me understand
you know
i think it's helping me more understand
why you say the things you say the way
you say them and and how
and how in a way i'm realizing more and
more that what you're trying to do is to
say well here's evolutionary theory this
was presents you know and this is the
limit because
it actually creates a disjunct in the
the person listening because it it
there's something
to us which is appalling or repulsive
about the idea that we don't have access
to reality and so then you bridge into
saying well here's a way in which i can
talk about reality which will afford us
some connection to reality but is with
his centered unconsciousness and not
centered on the idea of of cold
objective let's say uh perception of of
facts let's say something like that yeah
that's a that's a very good summary and
then the other thing about this approach
then is to say that
to really close the loop when we propose
this deeper theory
we have to show precisely
how it projects down into a space time
that leads to evolutionary theory
where that theory says i can't see the
truth so that we that way we close the
loop that's why we that's how we see how
evolutionary theory says you can't see
the truth but from a deeper point of
view you can see the truth and you can
explain why the the more narrower theory
tells you you can't see the truth
see that's that's and that's how science
progresses we we take our theories to
their limits
they tell us where they stop and then we
take a creative leap beyond but whatever
the new leap is we don't throw away what
we've already done we keep we treasure
those scientific theories they're
they're wonderful gems but we have to
show how they fit into
the uh
as you're saying the fractal or the
self-similar pattern at a deeper level
all right um so i want to come back to
something we're talking about before and
and so scientists love the the idea the
bottom-up part let's say you know the
idea for example as you formulated it
that consciousness can join together and
then they
then appear as a higher form of
consciousness but have you studied or
thought about the manner in which
higher consciousness constrained lower
consciousness within a fractal hierarchy
which is that do you see causative
relationship
moving down from higher beings into
into
their constituents or do you just see it
as a joining and then and then see it
going up let's say
well in one word yes but i'll unpack it
a little bit um
physicists themselves
recognize that
the standard reductionist approach is
doomed
so reductionism
strictly speaking is
the claim that as you go to smaller and
smaller scales in space-time
you get to more and more fundamental
entities and more and more fundamental
laws
and that has been the idea that
space-time is fundamental and that
physicist reductionism going to smaller
scales gives you more fundamental laws
and entities has been
a very very useful framework for
centuries in in science
but
the glory of scientific theories is to
tell you their limits
and
space time has revealed that it doesn't
go very deep it only goes to 10 to the
minus 33 centimeters and then it fails
not 10 to the minus 33 trillion
centimeters only 10 to the minus 33 so
i'm not terribly impressed so so that so
so reductionism
has a finite
lifetime it can only go so far and in
fact the physicists now are
looking at these what they call uvir
interactions
so the ultraviolet is as you go into
smaller and smaller scales but ir is
going is going to the bigger and bigger
scales and and before we used to think
that
as you go the uv direction to smaller
and smaller scales that's where you get
more and more fundamental laws but no it
turns out that it wraps around and as
you were talking about the global tends
to affect the small
as well as the small affecting the
global within
this is just within the physicalist
framework of space time and and and this
uh
this is state of the art issue in
physics right now the physicists are
trying to wrap their heads around this
they're trying to understand how this uv
ir interaction
is happening but
brilliant physicists are making real
progress on this let me be very
interested now that's doing it within
space time
i'm i'm trying to work on this kind of
thing outside of spacetime where the
notion of spatial scale no longer holds
there is a different notion of
self-similarity in terms of for example
the number of conscious experiences that
an agent can have so you can you can
talk about combinations being higher in
terms of this this
this conscious agent has all the
experience of these agents and more and
and there
i also see what you could call uvir
interactions where yes
bottom-up interactions of agents in
their asymptotics leads to higher level
agents but those at those agents and
their asymptotic interactions also
affect the low-level dynamics of the
agents below and that's a very very rich
mathematical area that that is going to
i
predict occupiers for centuries
on exploring all those possible
possibilities of bottom-up and top-down
interactions there is the riches and uh
you know i
i just see the the riches and the
distance and
i i would love to explore them but you
know it's
my guess is that it's going to be an
infinite exploration
definitely ah
and so because the uh
we experience it in ourselves right that
is the reason why i say that is that we
we experience it in ourselves in the
sense that we notice
at least i do like i'll notice
things that have agency in me
that i'm trying to constrain you know
that that seem to to have some kind of
agency and then i'm trying to to let's
say bring them in line with my higher
agency or my my higher consciousness and
i can and if i apply that fractally up
from me then i notice the same in
something like a city where a city is is
of course made up of all the people that
constitute it but it has laws it has it
has ways of constraining those members
in order for them to participate
appropriately in their higher in their
higher being let's say um and so you
know i i tend to use very practical
examples but i don't know if the
practical examples map on to your
theoretical examples
yes so
there's both the emergent properties as
you
so that's a word of a bottom-up kind of
thing so you can get emergent properties
the city is not just the people and the
cars and so forth there is something
more but that you could think of that as
a bottom-up kind of kind of thing but
then the city itself constrains what
people do and and it affects you know
the fact that i'm in irvine as opposed
to manhattan changes my lifestyle
considerably and how i would live so
there's going to be these bottom-up and
top-down things and as you alluded to in
our personal lives right we we notice
that
we're not just one
self-consistent consciousness ourselves
that we we you know
you may be aware of the split brain
work the literature so
if you you have two hemispheres a left
and right hemisphere and if you if
they're joined by a band of fibers
called the corpus closum 225 million
axons roughly and you cut that cut those
actually a friend of mine joe bogan was
one of the surgeons who who did those
colostotomies cut the corpus callosum
and uh another friend of mine uh
yes ramakantan we call him rama rama um
one of the patients that he studied the
left hemisphere i believe
believed in god in the right hemisphere
was an atheist the left hemisphere might
want to have a desk job in the right
hemisphere what wants to be a race car
driver and they can even fight the right
hemisphere controls the left hand the
left hemisphere controls the right hand
and they can fight you know
the left hand might be trying to make an
omelette and the right hand um doesn't
want an omelette and it and it throws a
full egg into you know with eggshell and
the whole bit into the omelet to ruin it
so so we
it
the kind of thing you alluded to we have
concrete evidence of
multiple agencies within what we call me
and that's what this theory of conscious
agents that i'm working on with my team
is really one of the things we're
interested in is how okay
how do these agencies interact and form
new agencies and yet preserve in some
sense the original agencies and and what
happens when you cut the corpus callosum
what does that do does it
is there a real disunification how how
does that work that we could just unify
um
previously unified agencies and and also
in spiritual traditions when they talk
about
you know the false self
versus the deeper true self
and and when you
spend time in meditation and in just
everyday life
and are aware of the the false self and
its need for
trying to be special and more important
than other people and and its tendency
to complain about everything and and to
worry and so forth and to think about
the past and future and never be in the
present moment versus another part of
you that that says you know
relax be here now and and you and you
see both going on in yourself at the
same time once again you get this notion
of multiple agency and almost the sense
that the fall itself is some kind of it
feels like some kind of autonomous thing
that that is going on of its own accord
and and that you know it in some sense
by paying attention to it
and not giving into it but just in some
sense embracing it it eventually dies
but it but it's it it's a painful death
for it so so that that whole and
christianity when jesus said you know
if you want to follow me take up your
cross daily you know deny yourself take
up your cross daily and follow me well
that that that denying yourself is
really what i was talking about this
this false self that's complaining and
and worrying and and wants to be special
and more special than everybody else and
be important
you know when people put you down and
you want to
snap back and repair that false self
right and and get back you know someone
honks at you when you're driving and you
and you want to honk back
when you
don't
and you feel that part of you that
that's angry and you let it die that's
what jesus is talking about is
daily letting that false self die so it
is very much like
a
another conscious entity
that that has some autonomy that
actually has to be killed so i would
love right now i don't have a
mathematical
grip on that but i would but but see you
can see where i want to go with it i
would like to take these ideas that are
informal intuitive and and give them
um scientifically you know deep
attention and try to to model what
what's happening in the left and right
hemisphere what's happening what we what
we call the the false cell how do
conscious how are their autonomous
consciousnesses how do they interact how
can they be united and separated
because one of the things we've been
talking about in this like circle let's
say a conversation that i'm part of is
the idea of parasitic agency that is
that we we can notice that there are
some
there are some consciousnesses or some
agents agents that seem to
exist
you could say something like exist in
service of their higher participation
and there are some agents which seem to
close off and become parasitic a good a
good image is to say that they become
prideful right they become prideful they
want to self contain and in
self-containing that is when they become
something akin to what you call the
false self is that they they're becoming
capable of noticing their higher
participations or even their lateral
uh contact you know because you know
in in this theory of consciousness i
imagine there's also a sense in which we
share
in consciousness that is there is one
ultimately one or there is
consciousness is shared among amongst
agents and it isn't something that
closes itself off and becomes a
a completely uh hermetic system let's
say
right in fact i think that
there is
one sense in which i could say that that
you and i are the same consciousness
right that there is in some sense uh a
unification there
on the other hand this false self that
we were talking about
seems to be where when
consciousness
has put on a headset
and
it doesn't recognize that it's
a headset it thinks it's the truth
and it's when it and
so when consciousness
it
lets itself get lost
it loses its own
identity and it thinks that it's some
little thing so i'm a little 160 pound
six foot thing
in this vast billions of light years
across space time so on this tiny
insignificant thing and i really believe
that i so identify with that that that
form that that
that experience of of the body
um as being just this tiny insignificant
thing
then then of course it makes sense that
i'm going to be spending my time trying
to figure out how to get myself sick how
can i be
how can i be significant you know what
can i do i i have to compete with
everybody i have to be smarter or more
famous or whatever it might be or have a
better car
richer but whatever i have to do
something because i i
because i'm believing a lie and and so
in some sense that false self is part of
is is
is part of the one big consciousness but
it's the one big consciousness that's
letting itself
identify with an illusion
and and that but and so it seems wrong
at one level and it seems perhaps evil
at one level
but at
a
at a deeper level
it may be part of the necessary process
by which consciousness really wakes up
and knows itself
by letting myself get completely lost
and doing evil things competing and and
and all that stuff and then waking up
eventually i i realized
um that i transcend that and i you know
i take my headset off and the others
take their headset off we find out we're
the same
we shake our hands and move on
yeah well i mean i
i think the idea let's say the idea of
repentance
if you if you apply it within yourself i
always try to move across the levels in
order to kind of understand the analogy
so within you
you will have you will notice those
things so it's like let's say hunger is
a good one it's like so hunger is an
aspect of agency which is is good if it
participates in its
in other with and let's say collaborates
with other uh aspects of agency within
myself but if i but if it takes over and
becomes parasitic and sees itself
believes its illusion right believe that
it's all it exists then i can become
then i can like say my higher self can
actually become a slave of that lower
of that lower agency and then i start to
serve it you could say and so i i live
for eating and i you know eating becomes
that which drives all my my motivations
and so you can see how
this this false this smaller false self
that they within me right is an image of
how
at even at a higher level i can engage
in
in these let's say false cells that that
will
capture my
my attention completely and cut me off
from my higher participation in
consciousness
right
and
we can ask why does consciousness
do that to itself why does it allow
itself to get lost that way and and i
don't know and i think that that's a
deep question that that that we'll want
to pursue
um both on just a spiritual
level but also on this mathematical
scientific level and i i suspect that
we'll be talking about it for a long
long time but one idea that that um
i would throw out as part of that long
conversation is
you do notice in some people that you
when they have a limitation
and they face it and rise above it
they they become better in some sense so
you know people who are in the
paralympics
they might be
they might be missing a limb or they
might be paralyzed or something like
that and and you watch it the ones that
or like a stephen hawking
right he you know motor neuron disease
he's completely paralyzed
and
he
faces it
and transcends it and we look at and go
holy smoke
look at the potential of the human
spirit you could be completely
confined to wheelchair unable to move
and you can become the greatest the most
famous physic physicist in the world at
that time
and and so that may be one i'm not
saying it's the final word but just one
aspect of what what consciousness is
doing by putting itself in these various
situations now here i am um a selfish
murderer
and and and then you learn about you you
learn about your potential and and so
forth by putting all these these
yourself in these confines
and then eventually you the murderer on
death row
waking up and realizing
and and realizing who they are before
you know for example before they're
executed
well
consciousness woke up and it it
so there's a so again i'm not at all
proposing that it's good to murder or
anything like that but i'm saying that
there's some deeper point of view that
we're gonna
i think ultimately have to understand
about what consciousness is letting this
this happen
and it may be like the stephen hawking
model maybe one aspect of it yeah
but i i think that i think that makes up
it makes sense because
what what can happen can i say this well
it also there's a playing out that say
when when a the 10 agency becomes
self-serving
uh
then it'll play itself out right let's
say the food part like if i just eat
like it'll play itself out and i'll
become sick i'll become overweight like
all these things will happen and in the
consequence of that as i see it unravel
then that is the point like that's the
moment when i am capable it's like you
know it's a cliche but it's like hitting
rock bottom right and and that is the
moment where i you know to use the words
of jonah right it's like i remember the
lord i remember the way what is above
all of a sudden there's a there's a
possibility of of connection again
because
this parasitic process has ran its
course and now it's devolved into like
it's broken down because it didn't have
what it what it needed to
it was it was acting in a way that was
uh reductive and was was was killing
itself let's say ultimately
yeah i agree it seems that consciousness
does have this built-in mechanisms such
that it lets itself be diluted but but
gives itself feedback painful feedback
like hitting rock bottom bottom to help
itself wake up
and and again the question is well why
does consciousness bother to go why does
it just stay awake and and there's there
seems to be some important reason why
consciousness lets itself go to sleep
and it and and you know we've talked a
little bit about it but i think that
there's a lot of gold there that we
haven't yet dug yeah and there's some
mysterious statements like there's a
there's an interesting statement by us i
think it's saint gregory of
nazianzis who says that there are the
angels of the right hand of god and the
angels of the left hand of god that the
angels of the left hand of god are the
demons
and that they think that they're acting
completely out of their own will and
that they are completely self-sufficient
and
even thinking that they're acting
against the higher will but ultimately
they're not it's almost like a trick on
them where ultimately it's a surprise
and they'll end up participating in the
giant pattern despite themselves
right and then they wake up and realize
that that the evil that they thought
they were wasn't
what they were at all that was just an
illusion that they were under um
yeah i think that that's definitely
at least it seems it seems to be but
it's difficult to pierce that of course
because you know it it's difficult to
pierce it
like you said without saying something
like the murderer is doing good the
murder isn't doing good the murderer is
is acting against
consciousness in a way but how can that
be if that's the source of all things
there's like a deep there's a deep
paradox in that problem
one way out of the paradox may be that
it's it's mathematically impossible
to
take a projection of the one
consciousness without necessarily
inducing these things as artifacts
that would be wonderful if we could
actually prove if we if a mathematically
precise theory of conscious agents could
prove that even if the one
the
is in some sense
without any competition all loving and
and so forth any
finite or or
projection of it that doesn't include
the whole will necessarily lead to what
we call evil that would be that would be
a very interesting theorem that would
that would resolve the question that
we're raising here we would
show that
that what we call evil is a necessary
consequence of not looking at the whole
as the whole as soon as you look at it
just from any particular perspective
evil is necessary and maybe the waking
up process is
emerging from a perspective back to the
poll
well definitely that's something that at
least from a christian point of view
that is definitely a difficult
proposition
because you would you would say
something i think the way that i would
formulate it as a as a christian would
be something like
that
multiplicity
you know is
in multiplicity is the is the
possibility of evil
because of its disconnection from the
one
but that the multiplicity can also be
filled
with the one ultimately that it can be
filled with the with love and that if we
see it's not that we abandon the
multiplicity for the one but that if we
see the manner and this is why the
headset thing is sometimes is an issue
for me because if if we see how the
multiple is connected to the one memory
is the image that we see for example in
uh
in i think for sure in the christian
tradition but in other traditions as
well the idea that in distance from
something remembering it connects you to
that and so it's not that you and all
the distance is that you remember and so
you can think of it in terms of time but
not necessarily you can think of it in
terms of just ontological hierarchies
where you know i'm a soldier in an army
and we're a bunch of guys and we're
goofing off and then suddenly we
remember that we're soldiers and we are
we are in this order let's say of
principalities and that is how i even
though i'm not the general right i'm not
the president i'm a soldier but by
remembering then i'm able to reconnect
and kind of reconnect these levels
together in a proper way so it means
that multiplicity would not would
necessarily have the possibility of evil
but not would not net would not
necessarily
have to produce evil
if it remembers
i don't know if that that might be using
language that you're not used to so i'm
sorry if i'm kind of pushing you a
little far in the way the language i'm
using
i think those are really fascinating
ideas and
and you can see why as a scientist i
would like to take them and make them
mathematically precise so that we can
actually start to prove theorems about
this this kind of thing
because the
these are the kinds of deep questions
that that that actually deserve that
kind of respect that deserve to be taken
seriously enough that we we start giving
mathematically precise answers to them
but but
you know in the bible
jesus talks about a deep unity between
all of us when when
when he he says you know for example
when he talks about heaven uh and most
of us typically think of heaven as some
glorious place that we're going to go to
after we die and and so forth but but
but jesus was very very clear about he
said the kingdom of heaven is within you
now
the kingdom of heaven is within you and
if we really this is actually the
kingdom this is the kingdom part that
i'm talking about kingdom is memory
because kingdom is the effect of a
principality on its possibilities right
so it's like the reign the kingdom is
the capacity of the king to reign over a
set of people
and so the idea of king heaven and the
kingdom of heaven are not the same
kingdom of heaven is something like
memory of heaven that is it is our
capacity as multiple beings
to
all look towards the king
and follow the king and therefore exist
as a body like the idea of the body of
christ let's say and so that's what i
mean by memory is that so when christ is
the kingdom of heaven he's not saying
although other statements that he makes
seems to actually imply deification but
in that particular statement he's saying
we we are able to be a body
of heaven the body of heaven like the
kingdom of the kingdom of heaven the
body of christ all these images that are
used in scripture to to talk about this
memory between levels um and so the
reason why i'm sorry i'm insisting on
this so much is just because
it's again the the
the difficulty of formulating
a relationship
to
consciousness as false
or as uh
at you know that multiplicity is an
illusion all these types of things
because there is and there is also a
there i think there is a little bit of a
danger sometimes in that because
gnostics that's what they that's what
they that's the way they presented the
world right like all this is an illusion
in a certain manner all of this is evil
right so we have to escape this we have
to escape this in order to enter the one
and often that created very strange
behaviors in people
whereas
the idea of memory for example or the
idea of connection between the levels is
admitting for the possibility of
breakdown and evil and illusion and all
that seems to
to fix the problem of
just positing our experience as illusion
let's say
right
so
you know my understanding of the spirit
spiritual traditions on this is that
we don't want to fight what is we don't
want to fight this moment we
the the
the bible's very very clear to um give
thanks always for all things right
that's pretty clear so that means that
i i'm hungry i should be grateful i i
have a broken leg i should
it makes no exceptions it says give
thanks always for all things so so
any anybody who says that we should be
you know angry and fighting this and and
so forth
you know if i see disease i should
and i'm a doctor i should go and help
treat disease and so forth like and if
it's a scientist i should go find ways
to but but in in the process i should be
grateful for the situation that i have
right now there is this disease and it
gives me the possibility to
find ways to
ameliorate disease and so forth so so
there's this
it's it's a subtle thing but it's on one
hand not resisting what not fighting
what what is on the other hand um then
choosing to take actions out of out of
love
and so forth but but the the issue of um
you know
jesus tried to use i think metaphors to
point to things that are that are
difficult like
the
the kingdom of heaven i think might be
translated the realm of heaven and
heaven just meant like spaciousness
i think that he was pointing
more to
what you might just call a sense of
spaciousness
or being
that we all share and and you know i
think that he suggested that all of us
have this in in when he
was confronted by some religious leaders
at the time who wanted to kill him they
were getting
stones to throw at him to kill him
because he said i'm the son of god and
he said well look
uh you know in the psalms it says i have
said you are gods yeah
and if they call them gods to whom the
word of god came why are you trying to
kill me because i said i'm just the son
of god jesus is making very very clear
that that he's
not better from than the rest of us
we're all and equally
sons of god and gods and and so when
when he says the kingdom of heaven is
within you i think he couldn't be more
clear that saying
we're all essentially you we're children
of god but
a children of a person
a children of children of humans are
humans
children of god are god
and and so i think the the message from
from the bible to me is
that
we are one and you and i are god under a
veil under a projection and we'll take
the veil off and and greet ourselves and
recognize that we are
that one
yeah but i think that i mean maybe there
is there there would be of course a few
little
there would be point of differences
let's say with official christian
theology people watching will know let's
say what i think about that but i don't
i don't want to insist on it but um
there is so there is a difference like
and you see it and i think you totally
agree with me uh because you talk about
this idea of self-sacrifice or you know
there is a difference between
the taking off of my veil let's say
or the grabbing of the apple that we see
in uh grabbing divinity for ourselves
which is what we see as the fall and
this rather canotic mode where i
actually empty myself of my
of my false self and in doing that that
is when i let's say encounter divinity
or that is when i am deified uh
uh but that there is there is a
difference let's say between those two
movements and uh and i think it's for me
at least it's important because there
seems to be a
a tendency a normal human tendency to
want to grab that for themselves and say
oh we are gods and so yeah that's mine
like i am i am god let's say in that way
right whereas i think what jesus
and by the way i should say i'm not a
theologian so that's okay
as an amateur but but um but
my my take on is that that
when jesus said you know if anyone wants
to
follow me let him deny himself take up
his cross daily
that
is really
letting go of identification
with your
form
and your your space-time location and so
forth all the stuff that you identify
with
and and then competing with everybody
else and trying to be better than and so
forth letting go of all when you let go
of all those identifications and
in some sense jesus was saying
recognize that this is just a headset
and you're wearing the headset you're
not a little thing in the headset
but but if you think that you're some
little player inside the game inside the
headset you have to let go of that
illusion and
recognize
that that you're not that so
so here i am in a virtual reality grand
theft auto game right and i i don't know
that i'm just completely lost in the
game so i get really angry when someone
hurts my car and i i want to to go and
hurt their car and i then i want to grab
all these i want to get this mansion and
i i want to
but eventually i realized holy smoke
that was just a virtual reality and i
was all worked up over nothing and if i
if i just understood
that this is just a virtual reality
headset
that's the deep spiritual insight all of
a sudden i would have equanimity you
want to hurt my car hurt my car you want
my money here's my money because this is
just a game
and that's that's what my my take is
that in some sense
you're not you're taking up your cross
and denying yourself is recognizing you
are not your avatar in the game
recognize that that avatar is just an
avatar that you have when you have the
headset on don't identify with that
avatar and as soon as you do that that's
complete spiritual realization
and so
maybe i'll ask you last question what do
you see as the the
what do you hope the future will be in
terms of especially maybe in terms of
the discussion we've had in terms of the
man in which your theories will connect
both the scientific world and the more
philosophical or spiritual traditions uh
what do you see let's say in in the
future in terms of of those types of
discussions
well i i look forward to really
productive discussions between science
and spirituality
you know the history it's been bad
galileo
imprisoned by the church
house the rest and so forth
the spiritual traditions christian and
eastern mystical and you know sufism and
so forth have for thousands of years
said that space time isn't fundamental
that there's a deeper realm
science
but but they haven't had any rigorous
they haven't had mathematical models of
it they so they've had they've had the
the deep and i think
in many cases correct well of course not
completely correct but in many cases
correct intuitions
science on the other hand has stuck to
space and time for the last few
centuries and things inside space and
time but they've sharpened these amazing
tools of mathematical precision
experiments
um and then
the scientific method where you actually
then take take your theories to task and
find out where they're wrong and then
transcend them
the two have been separate strands
strands now it's time for them to to
meet
because the science is now recognized
that even though focused on space time
for centuries space time is not
fundamental space time is doomed
but they have the tools it was good to
study space time so well that we
developed the mathematical tools and the
experimental tools now
as we step outside of space time we're
stepping into i think the realm that the
spiritual people in saying is there for
all along but they haven't had the tools
the scientists now have the tools and so
the two can start to work together
constructively and that's why i say it's
going to be
both exhilarating and difficult on both
sides because
we all have things that we deeply
believe that will end up being shown to
be
deeply false or or not nearly as deeply
true as we thought
on both sides and so that but that's how
we learn and grow we we wake up from our
dogmatic slumbers
so donald thank you so much for your
time and uh for let's say uh accepting
my my uh my uh freaky questions to try
to kind of understand you're thinking i
really appreciate it
my pleasure and my apologies for my
amateur theology
i have no i have no sense of the sign so
there's uh i think your your theology is
better than my science so thank you so
much
thank you very much jonathan okay